alright Jameis Winston reportedly
heading to the New Orleans Saints not
done yet but a one-year deal is being
negotiated as of yesterday it was close
cam Jordan very excited about it he
tweeted negotiating let's go I said cam
wants to eat a W with Jameis by the way
it was the Superdome in New Orleans
where Jameis Winston gave us that gift
for the ages of eating at W before game
against the Saints cam Jordan says
Jameis is one hell of a competitor with
untapped potential 30 to 30 with goat
tutelage mind blown emoji I added also
5100 passing yards so you put him with
Sean Payton you put him in a position
where he's got the Teddy Bridgewater
spot look this is Chris the first team
that I mentioned when it looked like
there wasn't going to be a starting job
for Jameis Winston go to the Saints let
your career have sort of a palate
cleanser get a chance to maybe play if
Drew Brees gets injured at some point or
maybe Sean Payton wants to show everyone
that Jameis Winston can do it so you put
Winston out on the field once in a while
just for giggles I I think this makes a
ton of sense for Jameis Winston to go
work with Sean Payton for a year have a
chance to play and maybe be like Teddy
Bridgewater next year where you're
getting a three year 66 million dollar
contract even though you've only played
five games in five years yeah I mean
that's right but it's a great move by
Jameis Winston I mean to me yeah Mike
you said it from the get-go you're
exactly right
you know I was kind of banging the drum
for the Steelers or the 49ers this would
have been my third choice you know for
those those reasons right Mike I mean
this is what we talk about you know it's
not don't go somewhere just to be the
starter oh yeah great you're the
starting quarterback look some crappy
team and then you don't play well
because the support system around you is
not good and all of a sudden you're back
in the same boat next year maybe out of
the league because now nobody believes
in you this is the perfect thing for
Jameis Winston's career like you said
clean pallet he's going to learn some
some new things about football you know
he's gonna learn how to play the
position better and at a more efficient
higher cleaner rate than he ever has
and like you said if he does get in
there one of the best old minds in
football too good running backs you know
tight end play receiver play all really
good with the creative play caller and
defense to where like we saw with Teddy
Bridgewater he didn't have to do great
things he just played well he took care
of the football and they went five and O
so from Jameis Winston standpoint I
think it's a brilliant move and really
for the New Orleans Saints this is
really smart as well yeah I agree with
you completely and look here's the thing
and this was the same situation that we
saw last year if Brees gets hurt you
need a guy who can run the base offense
Taysom Hill is not gonna run the base
offense if and when Taysom Hill becomes
the starter they are going to create an
offense for him and even though Sean
Payton suggested at one point in recent
weeks that Taysom Hill is ready to be
the number two guy it's clear that
that's not the case this was part of the
broader game of either drafting a number
two or signing a number two and that's
okay
we understand that sometimes coaches and
GM's have to say things they don't mean
in order to advance their strategic
objectives they still want to keep
Taysom Hill in that Joker wildcard jack
of all traps right and design an offense
for him if they decide to make him the
starting quarterback and the bottom line
is he's gonna be around for the next two
years we don't know what his role will
be but he now has a two-year 21 million
dollar contract to remain with the
Saints it's official it was announced
yesterday he was due to make about four
point seven million this year Chris as a
restricted free agent so they're giving
him another 15 16 million on top of what
he was due to make to stick around for
one more year it's kind of like the
jacobi per set deal last year and a bit
of a lower level but you know here's the
bottom line he gets security he gets a
payday he never thought he was gonna get
in the NFL and he gets that that that
certainty of two years with the Saints
and the opportunity to compete to be the
starter next year and we'll see how that
plays out if they get Jameis Winston
maybe they decide to keep Winston as a
starter next year and let Taysom Hill
continue to be in the jack-of-all-trades
role well yeah yeah I mean the Saints
bought themselves some flexibility
that's the biggest thing I mean we all
know this is going to be true
Brisas last year you know so too what
you said Mike yes they signed Jameis
Winston because yeah we still got Drew
Brees but the Taysom Hill you know
gadget runs and that whole offense is a
huge part of what they do so now to have
Jameis Winston they have a traditional
backup and they can run those those
quarterback you know Wildcat type plays
but Taysom Hill and not worry if he does
ding his shoulder or you know it hurts
his ribs just a little bit to go oh now
we have no backup quarterback now they
have Jameis Winston there so that makes
sense and then as far as the contract is
concerned yes it buys them some wiggle
room for next year too you know now they
got Jason Hill locked up they don't have
to worry about negotiating with them
once again they threw some money out to
them for this year for next year and now
they have their guy for next year and
they'll see what happens with Jameis
Winston but you know I think it was a
win-win situation for Taysom Hill and
the New Orleans Saints as we know
because Dru Hill Dru breezes is out the
door after this season and here's the
key the Saints don't have to worry about
messing around with the franchise tag
next year to keep a some Hill right in
place right that and they raved 910
million over what the franchise tag
would be via the extra money they're
giving him so it is a win-win it removes
the uncertainty and they drafted Tommy
Stevens in round seven this year and the
immediate reaction is this is a guy who
can be like a taste some Hill for them
right so he can step into that
jack-of-all-trades role if Taysom
becomes the starter in 2021 but also
also Tommy Stevens
since the skillsets similar he could be
the backup to Taysom Hill if Taysom
Hills the starter because if you have
Taysom Hill as the starter you need a
number two that can run the same offense
and it's not just about having the
quarterback in a position of comfort you
got ten of the guys on the field who
don't want to have to rip up one
playbook and pick up the other one if
the oh that's right is injured every day
and this is fundamental it's amazing
Chris how many teams don't do this it is
fundamental that you want your number
two quarterback to be as much like your
number one quarterback from a skill set
as possible and the Saints get it and I
think Stevens is there
because they envisioned still taste him
he'll to be the starter in 2021 Stephens
will be a backup with a similar skill
set and can run that same offense no
Mike I think you explained it
beautifully I think that's exactly what
it is I mean he's a guy Stephens big
he's really athletic you know I think
has a chance again for like what you
know what we've seen when Sean Payton do
with Taysom Hill can develop but maybe
into a better passer and teaching the
position and there's some potential
there let alone like you said when
Taysom Hill does take over if they don't
feel like you know RAM and him through
the line of scrimmage in the run game
all the time maybe this guy can develop
into being that type of guy too just to
take a little wear and tear off of Bill
so hey the Saints Sean Payton you know
hey orange crush and Twizzlers whatever
it may be the guy who's always on his
game and he understands how to build a
team along with Mickey Loomis and you
know that's why the Saints are who they
are they're they got a lot of smart
people and Sean Payton to me is one of
the best coaches we've seen in recent
history plus he's lying awesome Jordans
I'm surprised right Jordans Thursday
night the Friday nights were even better
within within seconds my son had an
image from somewhere of what those shoes
were and he sent it to me to make sure I
understood that he knows that your
credit card bill great shoes great candy
great quarterbacks great cook
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports